[Music]
children's movies are supposed to be
light and fun but when it comes to Moana
a few things are a bit off stay tuned to
find out the dark reason why Moana may
really have been connected to the ocean
are you new around here don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more great
videos like this now on to dark secrets
in Moana Disney doesn't want you to know
Olaf if you watch the movie Moana
closely you may notice that there are a
few familiar faces in it lots of Disney
stars make cameos in this film when you
least expect it
when you see a Disney character in a
film that isn't their own how does that
make you feel it reminds you that all
Disney films are tied together in a way
and what could be better than that
well this particular character sighting
left us feeling a little bit more uneasy
than we would have hoped at one point if
you look closely you can see a carrot on
mallanna's boat while there's nothing
wrong with a carrot being on a boat the
carrot may actually be the nose of Olaf
from frozen so if this is Olaf's nose
then Olaf is completely melted in frozen
he barely escaped being melted so it
seems cruel to include him in this film
just to show that he did finally meet
such a horrible fate that's not nice at
all Disney we hope no children saw that
as they would probably end up crying all
night
wet hair the animation in the movie
Moana is incredible let's take a moment
to pay close attention to the crazy
details that the animators included in
each scene they made everything look so
realistic that it's easy to forget it's
all just drawings but creating such
realistic scenes wasn't as easy as you
might think and it didn't come without
cost
remember how perfect mallanna's hair was
every lock seemed to behave like real
human hair
well that's no coincidence in order to
correctly animate the leaves hair Disney
hired hair models having hair models in
itself is not a bad thing but these hair
models had to be continuously dumped
under water
why because Disney animators needed to
draw what mallanna's hair would look
like wet but doesn't that seem
just a little bit extreme we all know
what wet hair looks like without having
to repeatedly dunk people in water to
figure it out but apparently Disney's
animators have never seen a wet head
before so instead of looking at pictures
of wet hair online they dumped these
poor girls in water again and again
granted Mona's hair did come out looking
amazing and very realistic but was it
all worth it abandonment lots of Disney
characters actually have pretty sad
stories a lot of them are motherless or
even completely parentless Aladdin was a
poor beggar who lived on the streets
Snow White was a princess whose
stepmother wanted to do her grave harm
Cinderella was a girl who was forced to
be a slave in her own house it's all
quite dark and not at all what we should
be showing children Moana is no
different when Maui tells Moana of how
he reached demigod status his story is
legitimately tragic yet Disney just
skirts over it to get to the feel-good
part of the story
Maui says that he was born to two mortal
parents his parents supposedly took one
look at him and didn't want him instead
of giving him up for adoption or to a
family friend or something they tossed
him into the sea to drown what kind of
fairy tale is this why was this not
talked about more his parents were
pretty much murderers yet that story
only received a few seconds of screen
time before Moana and Maui moved on it
makes sense that Disney doesn't want
viewers to focus on the dark storylines
but if they're gonna put them in there
and they can't just pass over it like
it's nothing demigod while we're talking
about that whole how Maui became a
demigod story there's one more thing we
want to point out so Maui claims that he
became a demigod after his parents threw
him in the ocean he says that the gods
took pity on him and made him a demigod
however that is not how the whole
demigod thing works the first is by
being born into it by having one mortal
parent and a god or goddess as the other
parent since Maui already said that his
parents were mortals and maybe the worst
people we've ever heard of it's pretty
safe to assume that he became a God
through the second
the other way to become a demigod is to
reach divine status after passing away
which means that maybe he did actually
drown when his parents threw him in the
ocean now he just says that the gods
took pity on him and made him a demigod
is he leaving out the fact that he had
passed away by the time the gods noticed
him and took pity on him if this is true
it makes the story a whole lot darker
than we originally thought Moana when
movies come out lots of people come up
with their own conspiracy theories of
what's really going on in the film one
Reddit user named Jill kara fat came up
with a theory that still has us shook
remember the scene at the beginning of
the movie where Moana first meets the
ocean well Jill kara fat proposed that
maybe Moana actually drowned during that
scene as her people grieved for her they
turned her image into a goddess of the
ocean who is said to protect the island
at first this theory may seem crazy but
think about it all throughout the movie
the fact that Moana was one with the
ocean was pushed on us
how could she be more one with the ocean
than if she was goddess of the ocean
another thing that makes this theory
seem realistic is the fact that she
encounters so many gods on her journey
no one from her village has ever seen
any of these gods so how is it Emma
Juana is able to see them because she
herself may be a good the heart of
defeating there are so many hidden
messages and themes in the movie Moana
if you don't pay close attention you're
liable to miss them all if you did miss
any of these things we don't blame you
you probably watch the movie for
enjoyment
so from watching the film you probably
gathered the importance of the heart of
Tippi d it's the most precious thing
throughout the whole film literally
without it to feed II turned into that
horribly scary monster to CAW but have
you ever wondered what effect the heart
has on people well reddit users sketches
from Midgard had an idea basically if a
human has the heart of 2pt it keeps them
alive think about it grandma Tala had
kept the heart for years and years to
keep it safe once she didn't have it
anymore she passed away so does that
mean that it was the heart that was
keeping her alive could be if this is
the case then the heart must really be
protected because evil people could
steal
and have everlasting life puah in almost
every Disney movie the star has a little
sidekick to keep them going and provide
comic relief at the beginning of Moana
we are led to believe that Moana psychic
will be puah hua is so freaking cute
that we were super excited to watch him
help her throughout the movie but
unfortunately that could never have
happened because puah may not have been
real he was a symbol of her need for her
family's approval writer Dan Levine
first proposed this idea think about how
at the beginning of the movie hua is
always following her around when she
first tries to go out on her own past
the reef he's with her
when that ends badly she realizes that
she can't take him with her she must
leave hua and the need for her parents
approval behind in order to fulfill her
destiny if this is true then it's a
little sad hua was so cute and would
have made a great sidekick throughout
the movie but if he truly does represent
moas need for approval then we
understand why he had to go better luck
next time to us no real danger in any
movie the draw is the storyline whether
it be action-packed of romance or
suspenseful people watch movies for the
obstacles the main characters have to
overcome Moana may be one of the movies
with the most obstacles that the main
character has to face she almost lost
her life in so many instances that it is
unimaginable that she was never harmed
it's almost too good to be true right
well that's because it may be remember
when we said that sketches from Midgard
had a theory that whoever wears the
heart of two feety their life will be
prolonged
well mallanna wore the heart for most of
the film which means that she was never
in any real danger
remember how every time she would fall
off the boat and into the ocean the
water would just magically put her back
on the boat yeah if that doesn't prove
that she was always safe then we don't
know what does it makes sense that
Disney didn't come right out and say
that Mulan his life was protected the
movie was much better this way
hua part-2 for some reason people are
obsessed with puah just search the
internet for half a second and you'll
see lots of theories and things that
have to do with puah have you noticed in
the film that no
one else really acknowledges puah other
than Moana weird right well it could be
because puah actually doesn't exist if
you notice hua is the only pet pig on
the island so maybe he actually isn't
fair he also just sort of disappears
while Moana goes on her adventure Kula
doesn't really add much to the storyline
so it wouldn't change much if he wasn't
real except for the fact that it means
Moana sees imaginary animals some would
consider imagining animals that aren't
actually there as crazy Disney on the
other hand just thinks of it as being
magical if Moana is missing a screw or
two that could definitely change the
meaning behind the whole movie the whole
adventure could have been something that
she made up in her head out of boredom
Disney what even is real that's it for
ten dark secrets in Moana Disney doesn't
want you to know were you surprised by
any of these secrets let us know in the
comments
[Music]